like p like to me everything's about
breathing right like to me everything is
about like take full ownership for
everything
and then everything gets easy because
then you're in control
and then learn how to love to lose
like for me my game's simple right it's
all my fault
so now i'm not mad at lindsay or drocker
that's it my fault
i'm empowering them so it's actually
true
my fault now
oh we lost this or this didn't deliver
or we [ __ ] up
all right
so now
like everybody's got losses you know
it's funny uh when ufc started getting
popular i started using it to paint the
picture i'm like look business and
entrepreneurship is much more ufc than
it is boxing in boxing a loss is
devastating
like you know if you ever you know if
you're i'm a big boxing fan like most
big fights like the big big big fights
through here almost it's just
unbelievable amounts of 33-0 versus 35-0
right just like that's like what you do
you don't fight anybody and you get to
that level
everybody's got losses in the ufc
and so
i think that's how that's how
entrepreneurship that's how life is we
all have losses
and so i like losses i love adversity i
like the climb i like the chip on my
shoulder i like when people are like oh
i knew it he's not that good that is
like like i'm even weirdly scared as i
continue to ascend and i'm getting
popular and
what do you say the marketing leading
like if people start putting these words
in front of my name i'm like
am i gonna sabotage myself
to like recorrect this like i like
adversity so
yeah all on me
you know i enjoy losses now all of a
sudden like what you become completely
invincible i feel invincible i really
genuinely outside of the health
of myself and 20 people feel 100
invincible as a person
i think there's a very very important
lesson in my story
most people don't realize that when i
started sun
with scott mcnealy we started another
company a month earlier
and when i see audiences like this
i always ask them do you remember what
company i started and failed
nobody can tell it was a company called
the data dump
in my point is the following
your failures don't matter if they're
manageable failures
my life wasn't going to end if the data
damp failed
uh
i'd be a little bit behind on my rant
but i'd pick up and start again
and
and we started both data dump and sun
about a month apart
same founders
uh and my point is failure doesn't
really matter
if it's not gonna kill you
success on the other hand everybody
remembers 40 years later
uh and it changes your life life and
frankly the failures also are probably
one of the more important learning
moments in your life
so i just want to emphasize
what seems like a large risk may
actually in the context of 10 20 or 30
years be a very small risk
because nothing about you changes maybe
you're a little bit smarter
but my point is people don't remember
your failures
and i like to say my willingness to fail
is what gives me the ability to succeed
i find
most people
are so afraid of failing they don't try
and do the things that would be
important enough to do
anything worth doing is hard
so
look
it would take an hour to talk about all
my mistakes i actually
let me put it this way
in the last 15 years there's only once
in my life i've called somebody and say
i'd like to speak at this conference
and there wasn't a popular conference is
a small thing in a hotel room in san
francisco it was called failure con
where everybody who had failed came
and i wanted to speak to this issue of
failure
there are so many
stupid things you know the ipad is so
popular
we tried to do it
probably one of my
large mistakes in the late 80s
um and i can go into details and i'll
cut it short
what i would say is i'm never
embarrassed about my failures
and so if you search on the web for my
failures you'll find lots of them and
you'll find me talking about them
it's important because
given my philosophy
where i screw up doesn't matter because
it's a long list in fact it's a longer
list than my successes but like i
started with nobody remembers the data
dump here
everybody remembers sun
right
the number of
venture companies where i made stupid
mistakes i'll tell you one of my
big failures
so if you go back to sun
1980s
sun's
logo or
model under the logo was the network is
the computer
and these couple of people started this
software program that did routing of ip
packets or network traffic
that happened to be the beginning of
cisco
now
when you say the network is the computer
and make these arrogant
marketing lines and you forget that
routing is the key element
and cisco was born as an application on
sun and we didn't see it
and i said to myself duh how stupid was
i not to see it when it was happening
even when i saw the application
a router was an application on a sun
machine we missed the largest
opportunity some could have i can find a
hundred such examples
the point is
try and fail but don't fail to try
my a couple of other favorite quotes
along those lines since we're coming to
the end of our time
robert f kennedy said only those who
fail greatly can succeed greatly
the classic example of that is elon musk
right
he said forget this [ __ ] about
supplying batteries to gm
they're just too slow to make change
happen
you know i was talking about retailing
amazon not walmart
youtube not nbc
think about gm or tesla
gm spent way more money than tesla did
space uh nasa and lockheed spend way
more money than spacex did i can go on
and on every major change
so failure
try and fail but don't fail to try
naseem talib in his book anti-fragile
which i recommend everybody read if
they're setting off on a career as a
personal philosophy
mine happens to coincide and i'm not
talking about black swan but his book
called anti-fragile
i always love ending with a
good book recommendation
i think that's important so
i'm just not embarrassed about my stupid
mistakes i mean i think that's the
difference
i think that here's
here's what's really fascinating is that
you know and i'm not sure if i'm going
to say this right and i know that
somebody whose name i can't remember
said this much better to you than me
the degree of success
that you will have in your lives
and that i will have in my life is not
related to how hard i work
or um
it's related to
how high a degree of failure i'm willing
to tolerate in my life
and so
if i'm only willing to tolerate a very
small amount of failure i'm going to
keep taking relatively safe things that
have relatively limited downside but
will also because that's the nature of
things when you know don't have a lot of
upside so
the guy who launches for a career in law
or career as a consultant or career is a
all these careers where
the the the sort of the outcomes are
relatively narrow you start with a
relatively high salary but where it pans
out 10 to 15 or 20 hours later is a
slightly higher salary or a partnership
salary but it's not sort of many many
multiples of what you could expect to
get
that's somebody who doesn't want to
tolerate a very high degree of failure
in their lives and then you get people
like ted turner
who spent
vast amounts of money of his own and
other people's money building up cable
news network the first news network
uh that was nationwide that was on cable
that wasn't uh one of the broadcast
networks at the time and and he was
willing to invest
five six seven years of his life into
something that might ultimately fail so
he was
and i suspect that if we look closely
and i i'm afraid i don't know this if we
look closely at um his life we'd
probably find a lot of
major massive failures
and another guy that we can talk about
is uh that we all know a little bit
better is steve jobs i mean you know he
was fired from his own company
uh he he spent a number of years out in
the wilderness
so
uh
my life you know in a certain way when
you look at the failures in my life they
just don't compare to some of the bigger
failures that other people who are way
more successful than me that have had
today i was reading about um freddie and
fanny it turns out that they've had some
major
uh judgment these uh guys who invested
in whichever securities bill ackman is
one and
um
uh
this guy uh
[Music]
bruce berkowitz is another and one or
two others of all are all losing large
amounts of money because they made major
bets on fedy and franny and it turns out
at least in the latest decision
uh that it's unlikely that they're going
to win
and so they're tolerating major failure
bill ackman lost on his freddie and
fanny position 175 million dollars
according to
uh the wall street journal today um and
he's he's a guy who's willing to fail
big
because he's got the fortitude and the
courage and the moral or the depth of
personality to take that because he
knows that over time he'll do
extraordinarily well he's a guy who in a
certain way lives much larger than i do
i think if i'd been willing to fail as
big as he has done
i would have had an awful lot more
success
financially and career-wise
today
what what advice
would you offer
my number one thing
would be to floss regularly
that's i think that's probably the most
important thing that i could add to this
class i'm not sure if there's anything
else bill do you have something to
contribute
sure so the piece of advice i give to uh
when i have the chance to speak to uh
young people
um particularly young people go to
schools like harvard
is the problem with where you are in
life right now
is that in order to get to harvard you
probably have not made many mistakes on
your path here meaning you probably
graduated something close to the top of
your class in high school you probably
did really well on your sats
you probably
you know had some great summer
interesting experiences you got great
recommendations
um
you had to live a pretty
you know successful path and then you go
to harvard
uh and you know
and you're surrounded by that group of
people and you're on your way to the
next thing and
the
the problem with that experience set
is that
success depends on how principally how
you deal with failure
and you've had very little experience
and failure and you know the lesson like
the sort of my words are what is
experience and experience is making
mistakes and learning from them so you
have to come to learn to treasure
mistakes
and also you have to come to learn that
you are going to experience
a series of unfortunate events over the
course of your life it's a certainty
right at some point your parents one or
more will pass away
you may have your your own health issue
or someone close to you uh you know you
relationships work
and and some fail marriages work and
some
don't uh and you'll take a job and maybe
it's even the first job out of school
and you'll [ __ ] up okay and
maybe you get fired uh and
you look at the list of successful
people you know i think just thinking
i'm i'm my bloomberg screen is up on
up just to the left of the zoom call you
know mike bloomer was fired from solomon
brothers right and
that firing catalyzed him to build a
company but anytime something really bad
happens you have to figure out why it's
good
uh and
um
you know and it's it's always the case
that bad turns into into good my first
investment firm
ultimately i was i had to shut it down
uh which is not it was a fairly
ignominious
end to something that we were on a very
very good path on for a meaningful
period of time but that was good why
because it allowed me to start purging
square
allowed me to start persian square and
with all the experience i had
at my first fund
and interestingly investors were
extremely interested in investing
because i
made mistakes and because therefore i
had experience and i think that's really
super important lesson so don't be
afraid of failure um you know
america in particular love second acts
you know in the in the venture-backed
world people really like entrepreneurs
who've you know
fallen
dust themselves off gotten up figured it
out uh but i think the most successful
people
in the world
have had to overcome i mean think about
reid hastings
you know his business was mailing you
three cds
and you know he's competing against
blockbuster and he tried to sell his
company to blockbuster for 50 million
and they turned him down
right think about that as an as a
because he was trying to make it work
and he could barely make it work and he
was afraid of this you know
multi-billion dollar competitor
but he failed to sell it to blockbuster
and now you know what's that business
worth today hundreds of billions of
dollars
so
uh just look at every failure as an
opportunity and if you do that
uh and you don't get discouraged you're
going to succeed
i think that's great advice i mean it's
not as good as flossing but you know as
a second bit of advice is good
actually well to paul's point let me
actually take paul's very humorous
comment and turn it into something
serious which is
you cannot succeed
unless you're healthy
and the time to start being healthy is
when you're 22.
and that's you know the keys to
healthiness are nutrition exercise
sleep
uh and also not doing stupid [ __ ]
which is what young people do like
you know driving drunk
doing you know just dumb stuff
uh we where the laws of probability
occasionally mean that you're going to
die doing it even if the chances of your
dying are only
1 in 20
whatever kind of stupid risks
people take you know one
one formulation of one of bill's points
was that sometimes you
that the most successful people are the
least accustomed and comfortable with
failure they're the least accustomed to
failure and so they're the least
comfortable with it and that creates a
fragility
uh because of the fear of failure that
they have
because they've just succeeded in
everything they've ever tried
and that leads to a sub-optimal risk
aversion
right
and
one of the things that i've said to
people is show me someone
who's succeeded at everything they've
ever done you know that that person
might say well do you people say wow
what a winner wow the person wins at
everything they ever do i say show me
someone who succeeded everything they've
ever done
and i'll show you someone who hasn't
reached farm
because the only way you know what
you're capable of is to reach for
something
that
you don't know whether you can do
and then sometimes you surprise
when you surprise yourself and that's
how you stretch and that's how you
really explore your boundaries
but one of the things that um
i think is endemic to our classmates is
that many of them
would take steps would only take steps
where their probability of success was
really high because they were they
didn't have the experience of failing
and then learning wow i can fall on my
face
and pick myself back up and go and this
is a very powerful lesson that bill has
learned i mean bill has the resilience
to do it but he also learned the lesson
of it
which which enabled him to try things
that other people wouldn't try
and much more thoroughly explore his
boundaries right and life is much more
resilient and forgiving than you realize
provided
that your failure isn't because of
character
if you're failures but a character it's
a whole different world right
if your failure is like hey look
tried something really ambitious it
didn't work so be it
if you fail because you did something
wrong that's a hard one right
and even so you can recover from it you
know
look at mike milken right people forget
now that mike milken at one point was
sent to jail for 10 years and had to pay
like a billion dollar fine the sentence
was later reduced to
you know whatever two years
um but i think the guy's made an
unbelievable recovery i think he's
extremely widely respected he's done a
ton of great work in
medical research cancer research
prostate etc
so you can even recover from that but to
paul's point um
the interesting thing about character
versus
even business success is everyone can
have exemplary character
it's just a choice
yeah because
some of this other stuff
you know requires some kind of acumen or
hard work or whatever but character is
is just a choice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you